what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel um
today i want to talk about a change
in my life um that i am actually making
because
of kevin samuels and because of the man
of sphere so
um i've watched
probably hundreds of hours of just like
manosphere content kevin samuel's
content
and in um the kevin samuels content he
constantly talks about
how important like therapy is
and i didn't really realize um
some of the trauma that i might have
like held on to just from like previous
relationships or
um you know just stuff growing up i had
like a pretty good childhood i'm not
here to complain about it but what i
realized is i really want to be married
and i used to think that like there was
someone out there that's just like
perfect for you
um and what i realized is you really
have to work
to deserve and to earn a husband you're
not just given a husband
um so because of that like my goal is i
really want to become in the best
physical shape of my life in the best
mental shape of my life i need you guys
to hold me to this if you don't see me
working out on my story hold me to it um
but yeah just like listening to what
kevin samuels talks about
um physically like i'd really like to
lose
20 pounds in the next year i think that
would put me in a really healthy weight
um for my height and mentally i actually
signed up for my first i've never been
to therapy before other than like
maybe one session when i had a cousin
die when i was little but i don't really
count that because it wasn't like
consistent
um but
yeah i signed up for my first therapy
session on
tuesday and i don't know i'm actually
really excited because
i really just want to be the best
version of me i'm not competing with
anyone else
i just want to be the best version of me
so when i do have kids
um i can you know raise them and when i
do get married
i can raise like the happiest home
possible for those kids um and it's
really something i never really thought
about
um before watching like manosphere
content and watching kevin samuels show
is that you really have to like deserve
a husband and i think over time
if you don't put yourself in the best
physical and mental shape possible
you'll see repercussions
whether it's like your kids overeating
and your kids having health issues
or your kids having mental issues so i
don't know i just wanted to share that
with you guys
i'm really excited for it and i'm going
to keep you guys updated on how it goes
so i love you all i'll talk to you later